all right hey guys
so yes i didn't miss the wood and then i
changed it
i'm not good at this whole uh live
stream thing
we'll get there
i shouldn't have put it public before i
was totally ready but
that's what i didn't notice so i figured
that
i figured that sorry i just need to mute
this
so i figured that i done a stone carving
but i didn't do any wood carving with
you guys so
i'm going to show you a little bit of
wood carving
so for those who have been following the
story a little bit
i am actually
starting a i put online a uh
icon carving class
and uh and so this is the actual icon
that i used to
make the uh the the class but i made two
at the same time
and so the other one was finished this
one is not totally finished so i'm going
to continue it with you guys
if so for those of you who watch the um
the stone live streaming wood carving
takes longer so i'm probably not going
to finish now but i
am going to kind of play around with it
and show you guys what i'm doing at the
same time
and it will obviously give you an
opportunity
to uh to ask questions if you want to
ask questions i'll be more attentive to
the chat i have a tablet next to me
and so i can answer general questions if
you would like
and at some point you might hear my wife
because she said she might call me for
something
so we'll see
all right so this is an image of saint
john the foreigner
and like i said this is the image
that i did for the wood carving class
it's very interesting this whole wood
carving class thing because i was
supposed to go
to saskatoon to teach a wood carving
class
and uh because of covid it was kind of
like semi-legal it wasn't totally clear
whether or not we get in trouble
for doing that so they asked me if i'd
be willing to record
the uh the carving session and send it
to him so i thought okay yeah i'll do
that
and i left myself a certain amount of
time
and i grossly misinterpreted
how much how much time it was going to
take me to make this
not to carve the carving but to uh to do
it while explaining and then to edit
and so um the first week of
lent uh there were like 20 guys
pretty catholic guys who had taken off
work to come do this workshop
but it was taking so much time that i
wasn't going to be ready to send them
the
the different steps and so the first
week of lent i basically slept like two
hours
a uh two hours every day
you know it was pretty nuts so i was
able to
to put it all together and so once i had
put it all together i figured hey
since i basically killed myself for a
week making this
i might as well try to put it online and
see how people react and the
reaction has been pretty positive in
terms of uh online as well
so um all right
so michael also says welcome to
christian asmr yeah a lot of people said
that about
the uh the stone carving because you
could kind of hear the scraping and the
stone carving you're gonna hear the same
with the with the wood carving as well
you have that nice uh wood carving sound
there
so you won't get in i won't be showing
you obviously we're already in the
details here as you can see
so you won't get that you won't get that
really nice wood carving sound that you
get
that's not bad actually
so emil sunstrom asked i am so confused
are you a christian
why are you confused about that what
makes you confused that i'm a christian
you think i wasn't a christian
yes i am a christian hopefully that
answers your question
and so you're actually you're actually
all arriving at
in this carving at the moment that is
the least
um are you seeing everything here
maybe i should lift it up a little bit
at the like least
uh systematic part of the actual carving
which is the uh
i'll get the top like this that way
you'll see everything um
which is the hair because the hair is
kind of wild
and so there's a there's more
improvisation with the hair
than with other parts
so i have to kind of create these locks
here
because he has pretty wild hair
so tara asks what kind of wood am i
using this
is called basswood basswood is a
i would say basswood is like a general
name for
several types of wood which are this
light
soft wood and
this one is called northern basswood the
the technical term is actually linden
and so it has it definitely has an it
has a
it's a really good wood if you're in
north america and you want to
you wanna carve and you have a car
before getting northern basswood is
really the way to go because it's pretty
it's easy to carve it has a nice light
golden color
doesn't have too much grain it's good
for carving figures because
you know when people carve figures out
of you know some wood is really
beautiful because it has all this
beautiful grain but when you carve
figures
out of wood that has massive grain
sometimes the the the grain of the wood
will
compete with the uh the the figure's
expression or the details in the figure
so emile surgery says the reason i'm
confused is that you have a very
intellectual approach in your philosophy
you're not fundamentalist
you know there are non-fundamentalist
christians and there are always been
very intellectual christians
uh it's just that sometimes
the well let's put the blame on to on
both sides sometimes
uh not very intelligent christians make
a lot of noise
and this plays right into the hands of
the
anti-christians who really like to point
to the
non-intellectual christians as being the
representatives of what christianity is
so but if you read
church fathers like saint gregory of
nisa or saint uh
maximus the confessor or you know
saying dionysus the areopagite you will
find that
is it is very intellectual
um and that's not to say that i have a
problem with people who are less
intellectual i think there's room for
kind of everything
in in the church it's mostly
the problem is always when people how
can i say this
the problem is when that when people
don't let others be
where they have to be and so when
non-intellectual christians
go after intellectual christians because
they somehow they don't like
they don't like how they don't
understand everything that's being said
then that's a problem and then when
intellectual type christians attack
the more kind of i would say grounded
maybe less intelligent or less
intellectual type christians then
they're also they're missing the point
of all this
so david b asks can you carve maple is
it doable yes it is i've carved maple
before
it's hard uh you know it'll take a while
and
and it's if you want to carve something
detailed you can actually if you had a
good piece of maple
that doesn't have too much grain you can
actually
carve quite a bit of detail in there the
craziest thing i did was
i made this uh you can find it on my
website actually
i made this this chalice
that has the silver lining inside but
the the actual
frame of it is made out of out of wood
and and i
i made it out of maple to make sure it
was like a nice hard noble wood
but the way that i designed it the the
base was turned and then at the top of
the base there were these patterns that
around the top of the base
this was when i just started doing this
kind of professionally
and what i didn't realize is that i had
to carve this ornament in the
in the in the head of the grain the head
of the grain means
the top of the grain where the grain
comes up like this
and my goodness that was just insane i
would never do that again
took me forever and it was so painful
so if you're gonna carve maple don't
carve in the head of the grain but most
people wouldn't be
stupid enough to do that in the first
place
you know i'm people don't like i'm
really not
a super technical person i'm not very
good at the whole tool
technical part of carving i'm more i'm
better at the formal elements of it
and so um and so in terms of the
technical stuff i learned but i
i learned with some pain let's say
so i'm basically wanting to create some
waviness in the hair and some kind of
crazy
because uh because saint john's hair is
kind of wild
hey adam chillard is there it's good to
see you adam
just sent me by email a
bronze icon that he that he made it was
carved
uh out of wax i think and uh
he cast it in bronze it looks amazing
that's pretty proud of him he
adam is was one of my students one year
and he's continued
uh carving i adam by the way
when when adam took my class he carved
this little saint christopher
out of uh soap and i still have it right
there in my workshop i keep it around
it's pretty cool
so not sam says i make music i don't car
but you still inspire me to do art
that's great we need
we need better artists
we need we need artists with the right
perspective on things and the right
point of let's say the right uh
vision of the world
so i'm kind of improvising with this guy
here i'm going to add more locks than
what i usually do
i'm just kind of going to have a little
fun here
so because this is a soft wood you'll
notice that i use a knife to cut
around the forms it just makes it easier
and more precise
you know the problem with the softer
wood is
that it also doesn't hold detail as well
so you have to be careful because if you
just go in with a
with chisel sometimes with gouges
then you can uh
you can mess it up and then you're in
trouble so obviously if i was carving
stone or harder wood
i would just go straight in with the
mallet but here i'm not even using a
mallet i just use a
just push
according to john says when a mother
complains about my long hair i just
remind her that my patron saint
is saint john the foreigner if i was
your mother i would say
that's fine if you're a prophet and you
go out into the uh
in the desert and eat locusts but i'm
joking obviously i have long hair too
my long hair is usually out of uh
lack of attention you know like i would
actually rather
have shorter hair and then not short but
just not
long but then i really hate getting my
hair cut because it takes time and it
means that i actually have to like call
the place where i get my hair cut
and so what ends up happening is my hair
just kind of grows long until i get sick
of it and then
and then i call or i ask or or i plead
for my wife to call and make an
appointment for me i'm like come on you
please make an appointment for me
so you can see i'm making waves in
different directions
so i'm uh i'm making waves like this but
i'm also making waves in and out like
that to create that
uh that kind of waviness
so mcf asks if i have any
any uh opinion or
resources on painting i mean there's a
there are plenty of resources on
painting
it's not you know you can learn all
kinds of places to learn to paint
it depends if you mean learn to paint
icons or if you need to just learn to
paint in general
right now is probably one of the best
times to learn to
to make art because there's so much
available
you know you can just you know i can see
because i some because
these days are let's say in the past few
weeks
what i'll do often in the evening with i
sit with my 13 year old daughter because
she really wants to
to get better at drawing and we'll just
sit at the table and we'll draw together
but i just realized how much how many
resources she has just because of
pinterest you know she just
she wants to say she she's drawing
something and she wants to
to to add like uh i don't know like
she said oh i want the sheet uh to look
crumpled on the bed or
i want the you know i want this to look
the certain way and she can just look it
up on pinterest and then she has an
example
which we did not have back in my day
so it's actually a pretty good time to
learn to to paint and to draw
if you guys are looking for a good book
based uh for
icon painting uh in terms to get to know
the basic it's obviously better to learn
icon painting from someone if you can
you know uh obviously with covet it's
complicated now but
it's better to learn from someone but if
you can't learn from someone
then there's a aidan hearts book
called i think techniques in icon and
fresco painting
is really the best book on icons out
there because
he has he has whole sections on the
meaning of icons he has a section on the
history of icons
he has a section on like the composition
of of the major
major importance icons and then he
teaches you how to make gesso
how to make your board like it's it's an
amazing book
it's hard to imagine a book like that
actually exists
by the way uh who is it is it team on p
says jesus with long hair this is not an
image of jesus by the way this is an
image of
uh saint john the baptist saint john the
foreigner and so this would be
if you guys watched my my uh
live stream on um stone carving
you'll notice that i did an image of the
virgin just her face kind of pointing in
the other direction kind of pointing
like this
well this this is that image of the
virgin and then
this image of saint john and in the
middle would be an image of christ
is what's known as a deises um and so
usually i mean you can have just the
face or the half body or the full body
and you can see that it's saint john is
is bowing to christ and he's showing us
with his hands you know he's got his
he's got his hands out and he's kind of
showing us
christ um and so that's what's
that's what a day assist is
and so if you if you're if you're
interested in learning to carve if you
take the uh
the online icon carving class what i'm
doing is i'm gonna go through the three
icons so i did this one first
and then after that i'm going to
i'm also going to do an icon of the
mother of god and then finally an icon
of christ in the end
and each icon has its own
particularities like this one is really
the hair and the beard as you can see
with all these locks and stuff and then
the icon of the mother of god is mostly
about
clothing because she has all those folds
and then the icon of christ is kind of a
mix of the two
uh plus with some detail like the book
all right so pringle dingle asks
sprinkle dingle my goodness
he asks thoughts on paradise lost
you know i'm not
a lot of orthodox are really hostile to
paradise lost
and uh i'm not that hostile to it
i think that i think that it has
i think it helps us understand what's
going on in the world
and i think that um
so for example i'll give an example this
is actually related directly to what
i've been working on
in the past uh those who follow me on
social media
i i i've been working on uh
a video to talk about the mark of the
beast but it's actually really hard
to be succinct about it and uh and so
i'm i'm struggling to get through
writing up the text
and and so what i'm doing is i'm
procrastinating but
i remember my um my first roommate said
i was the most
productive procrastinator he had ever
met so while i'm procrastinating
i finished my image of the uh the flood
you know of the the image of the of noah
in the flood
and then i just i made i was gonna make
a video
on uh little nazex and uh the symbolism
around his kind of satanic shoes and the
satanism that he portrays in his uh
in his video uh and then some
and then a strange thing happened i was
i recorded the video on my camera
and uh then when i went to transfer the
the video onto my computer
from the camera the uh the file was
empty
it was like there was nothing in it it
was just zero bytes and there was
nothing in it so
i thought ah that's funny and what was
weird was that i had
recorded little videos around it like
just to test the light and to
you know to make sure that everything
was okay and those videos were fine it
was just the one video that had
that had my commentary on these satanic
shoes and everything that were gone
anyways so i just left let it be because
i did it in the evening
the next morning uh actually i think
early in the afternoon the next day
i thought okay i'm i'm willing to do
this because it was improvised at first
so
that takes up a lot of mental energy so
i said okay i'm gonna i'm gonna do it
again i'm going to re-record it so i
record the whole thing
and it's it's a long thing it's like 40
minute video
both times and uh same thing happens
it's like the one of the files this time
so i there were two files and then one
of the files ends up being completely
empty and
uh and so i'm like okay forget this like
i'm not
i'm done i'm not doing this um anymore
and i just joked about it kind of online
as if it was kind of spooky
that this had happened and then i i got
like 500 comments
on that you know people saying oh you
got to put it out you got to put it out
you put it out and
then i got a i actually got an email
from rodriguez who said
what are we going to say in the video if
you write it up maybe i can publish it
you know
so i thought okay i'm going to do this
so so in the past few days i i wrote up
a 4 000
word essay about the symbolism
of that video and of also one division
and how it relates to what's going on in
culture today
so to get to paradise lost because yes i
know that's what the question was about
um and so what i tried to explain is
that one of the things one of the
accusations people
level against christians you've probably
heard this is
that the figure of the devil let's say
that it's a kind of composite figure and
that it's something which
was uh made up or that
was transformed with time and how
uh you know through influence of latin
medieval imagery
then through uh through kind of the
the early modern witch trials then
finally through something like paradise
loss and also
faust's um
faust uh methistopheles and so
and so they they kind of do that to
dismiss the uh
the image right the image that you see
and kind of pop satanism and the image
seen in movies
and the image that that christians will
talk against let's say
um and so what i've been trying to help
people see is that
you're missing the point you're missing
as usual scholars always
very factual mostly missing the point so
they're missing the point which is that
the story of satan how the image of
satan
has transformed from let's say a kind of
shadowy vague figure
in the new testament and in uh in kind
of jewish
text the movement from that to this
like romantic promethean figure that
curses at the sky
which goes further even than than that
image because
the uh milton's milton's uh
lucifer was then used like recently was
used to
as a as the basis for neil gaiman's
lucifer character in
season of mists which was then the basis
of this
netflix tv show called lucifer um and so
and so the critics will laugh at
christians who find this offensive
because they'll say
it's all a fictional thing based on
milton based on neil gaiman based on
blah blah blah
and like again but once again i'm
telling people you're missing the point
the point is the very narrative
transformation of the devil
from that into this kind of uh
promethean
tragic figure is telling you about our
world it's telling you about
what is the value what are our values
what it is that we think is important
and how you know how the image
of the devil has now almost become a
heroic image
and so what what you know my point is
basically that it's manifesting
the end of christianity in a
mythological
frame um and so
so anyway you can read the article when
it comes out i hope it's going to get
published if not then i'll put it up on
the symbolic world
and i might record part of it i'm not
sure i want to record the whole thing
because
because it's written i give myself
permission to uh
to to cite a few more spicy things that
are in his
uh in uh little nasdaq's video and it's
not something that i would necessarily
want to hear myself say out loud
anyways but i it's you know at first i
didn't want to talk about it but i can
see that the same patterns that are in
this this uh
this little nozzex video are the same
which are in one division so
it seems like it's something that's
going on and is worth talking about
all right so
drew flasher says for ten dollars as i'm
a christian most influenced by the
reformed protestant tradition
recently inspired by faith in
perspective he suggests a great first
or collection of early church and desert
fathers
huh in terms of the church fathers
i mean a good if you want to ignore it's
probably best to buy
something like like the orthodox
the orthodox way by metropolitan
callisto's where that's a really good
book
in terms of helping you understand the
kind of the ethos
of the orthodox church and you know how
there's kind of this synthesis of the
the thought of the church fathers
that's definitely something
um but there are so many
so much online now like there's so many
texts of the church fathers that are
online
it's not that hard to to find
i mean i would say like for sure read if
you read
the life of moses by saying gregory of
nesa that's a good beginning in terms of
uh
change sorry my wife is calling me i'll
be back
okay
all right sorry we're still having work
on our house done and so
my wife says oh the because we had the
porch wasn't finished
now she's telling me the porch is
finished you should come see so i'll
come see
soon yeah dominic palermo says santa
from syrian hymns of paradise yes
for sure especially for someone who who
from a protestant background who
takes seriously the bible and scripture
and and uh
and loves the stories in scripture saint
ephrem's hymn of paradise is wonderful
because
uh it can also help people understand
the idea of kind of interpretation
through narrative which is something
that
people aren't used to thinking about
people aren't used to thinking about how
even within scripture let's say the new
testament is
interpreting the old testament and so
it's a it's kind of interpretation
through narrative
where you know by commenting
by adding you know by pr making certain
things
more precise in from the old testament
it's
actually interpreting not interpreting
in like a relative
uh you know you know just relative
relativistic sense but interpreting in
the sense of helping you see what's
already there which might have not been
visible
to you at the outset you know and so
like a good example is of course in the
epistle of jude when it says that
uh you know say michael uh contested for
the body of moses
before they entered into the promised
land it's like that's not in script
that's not in the old testament but
this idea that this would be brought
about like that this tradition would
then
be told to us what it does is it
actually helps you understand
why is it that moses couldn't enter into
the promised land
because it has something to do with
characters like enoch and characters
like elijah
who let's say don't cross over
you know that ascend into heaven
it's as if heaven reclaims its highest
thing
uh in order to cause a kind of
transition
um and then the transition happens uh
and then other people will will be the
ones to start up the new world
and so yeah that's really interesting
stuff
um have you this guy says have you read
childhoods and you're familiar with the
story no
i don't know i don't know about that
story i don't know what that is
childhood's end
is it a fairy tale of some kind
so arthur asked if i've read anything
from mario
ferreira de santos no i have not
his treaties on symbolic languages don't
have an english translation yet i know i
i don't know is that someone
is that a in portuguese or is that in
spanish i know a lot of people
have been pointing me towards
towards portuguese um
writing
so steve bradford says would you advise
non-orthodox to refrain from making
icons um
and so i'll be totally honest with you
why does it keep moving sorry my camera
keeps moving
uh i don't know i wouldn't i wouldn't uh
i wouldn't
recommend that non-orthodox make icons
uh i think that
discovering the language of icons can
help uh to help people that aren't
orthodox to kind of understand uh
but at this but i would also say that we
as orthodox
we need to be be careful because
obviously if if not orthodox people are
making icons then they might not know
what they might not know some of the
important things that are being
represented in icons and so
you know you have to be a little you
have to be attentive and not buy
heretical icons if you've got
non-orthodox people doing icons and
i mean in the end it's like you're not
going to stop people from making from
making icons
if uh you know the language of
iconography
is actually the universal language of
christianity it was
you know before the west started going a
little wild with the renaissance and uh
and the baroque it was the the languages
that
that crossed over in terms of east and
west were very similar
you know the the it was almost it really
was like this kind of universal language
which was developed in the uh
in the church so jacob is there
hey good to see you man brad is there as
well that's good to see you guys
there thanks for dropping in so jacob
says that his wife
uh that it helped his wife uh to
understand some things to make icons
i know you see that like jacob wasn't
orthodox and then his wife
let's say plunging herself into into
iconography having
being someone who has some artistic
talent was probably part of her own
conversion experience and
and now his whole family is orthodox so
as usual i'll say it again it's all it's
all about hierarchy it's always about
hierarchy
someone asked if i've seen the animated
movie the prophet based on the work of
uh
kelly gibran no i have not seen that
i read that book a long time ago like
really a long time ago and so i don't
remember
i don't really remember very well what
it was about
my impression like memory of it was that
it was kind of new agey
and maybe i say that and i'm being maybe
i'm being um
i'm not being generous towards the work
just because just because new age type
people like that book maybe that's why i
think that
so so i maybe if i'm wrong then
it's possible that i'm wrong right so
you see i'm cutting
that's basically the idea is that i want
to make sure that i've got these cuts
right
mostly because the wood is so soft this
wood is so soft that um
oh that's why it's moving it's because i
knock the camera with my
turning table i have to not turn it so
much
um so lisa is there that's awesome good
to see you lisa
um she says can you talk a little bit
about
the evaliant taylor
um yeah it's the valiant taylor
obviously is uh
is is about the the the problem of
boasting you know at least at the outset
that's what it is
but i'd have to i'd have to read it
again
all right so you see i'm i'm making the
the beard
to make the the beard it's almost i'm
making these staircases
so i put i'm putting each strand behind
the other
but they're all on the same level like
they're on the same level it's just that
i i will tip
the the beard under
like that so
matt the hazard says does new atheism
woke culture need to completely kill
christianity in order for it to be
resurrected and reinstated as the norm
look i don't know how it's gonna play
out let's be totally honest
um i don't know how it's going to play
out like i don't know how far all this
has to go
you know there's that famous uh verse
where christ says
you know when the son of man returns
will he find faith in the world it's
like
the fact that that christ is even asking
that is i mean it's scary
there are other places where it seems to
suggest a remnant
of some kind of a remnant um and so
and so i don't know i don't know how
it's going to play out but
it's going to play out
because right now we're really in this
weird like antichrist pattern
you know that is uh it's hard to avoid
it's hard to
hard to deny i talked about that in this
in this article on uh little nasdaq that
i wrote so you'll see a little bit
you know obviously talking about about
reni jihad as well and his ideas about
the scapegoat and victim culture
but i try to i try to expand that a
little bit
and talk about just upside down
you know the like a good example that
you see the difference between
let's say normal christian thinking and
what's going on in the world today is
that
there is a sense right there is a sense
in uh
there's a sense in christianity that
let's say christ
the image of christ going out and
finding the lost sheep okay
so there is this sense of let's say even
leaving the majority behind
in order to go out and save the lost
sheep
and so because of that type of imagery a
lot of people get duped by
social justice thinking because they
think that that's what's going on right
so let's say the way that the way that
we're treating
kovid the way that we're treating uh you
know exceptions all of this
is the way is this image of christ going
out to find the last sheep but
it's actually the very opposite of of
that
and so it's it's it's actually not
christ going out to
get the lost sheep it's the lost sheep
that is demanding
that all the other sheep be put in the
wild like they are
it's the lost sheep demanding to be the
measure by which all the other sheep
is measured and by which all the other
sheep are recognized and so
it's it and so it's like it's not
you know it's it's it's it's a it's like
an upside down version
of the story of the lost sheep
um so it's very it's very strange
um so someone asks i miss the name sorry
someone asked if i'm i'm aware of george
mcdonald yes i am not a lot
he's one of the people that are on my
list that i that i definitely need to
look into more
you know with uh people like paul vander
clay talking about
him and uh and others who like c.s lewis
and all that so for sure i'm going to
there's even some people who wrote about
george mcdonald for the
for the symbolic world blog so he's
definitely on my list
but it's like there's so many things to
read in the world
um let's see
[Music]
so wild child says i dislike the normal
doghole and wedge type
carving bench would you be able to
describe yours is it a lazy susan yes it
is a lazy susan
and how do you get at the same position
after rotating
um so this was made by my cousin itien
who's an awesome
guy who's an engineer he's actually uh
an
aeronautics engineer and works on like
f-16s and stuff
but he he made this for me like a while
ago i would say
nearly maybe probably eight years ago or
seven years ago and so it's basically a
lazy susan underneath
and then this board on top so that's why
it can turn like this
right uh but then on on the side i can
show you
i want to see sorry move the camera a
little bit so there's this
there's a um there's a handle when i
push the handle down
there's a screw underneath and it uh it
clamps
the uh the lazy susan together not
together it just clamps down on the lazy
susan and stops it from moving
there's like a rubber like a little like
a little piece of rubber on the um
on the that that goes up against the um
the lazy susan and stops it from
rotating so
yeah it's pretty cool
so wood carving is it requires me more
attention you can see it's like i'm
going slower
i'm not just banging away at it like i
did with the stone carving
stone carving i find is more natural to
me
uh also because i can use a mallet and
wood carving is is uh i find trickier
but it's more accessible at the same
time which is why you know the the wood
the icing class that i put online it was
a it was a wood carving class because
the the wood is easy to find the uh the
tools are easy to find you know
whereas if i was going to uh to carve
stone for a class it'd be a little
complicated because i don't know where
you would find that stone
the stone i get you know from kenya and
i
import it from kenya
and so i said that i was i was um
there's so many things insane but it's
good stuff like it's good it's good but
there's so much going on
i'm because i'm redoing like i'm
rebranding
the the website and redoing um we're
redoing
even maybe like redo the logo and we're
going to
to redesign the whole website so that
it's easier to access the different
different information there's going to
be a french aspect part of the website
so there's a lot of stuff going on
kind of in the background um
and so i need to
i need to definitely make some videos
soon that's for sure
so one of the videos i might be doing
too very soon is i
when i first did these uh these videos
on the kind of
satanic symbolism of little nazix i
explained
the the upside down pentagram a little
more
and so i was going to do that in the
article that i wrote
now for on all that
but for some reason in writing it it
didn't fit so well into the whole thing
and it's like it was
it was one thing too many so i didn't
and so maybe i could make a video on
that
um it'd be like a compliment to my video
where i
try i try to debunk the
people who get freaked out when they see
geometric shapes and they think that
they're automatically satanic
i could make a video which you know
still explains
why these symbols are used like there's
a coherent reason
why let's say an upside down pentagram
would be used by
by people by kind of satanists to
manifest their
their um their thinking or their their
rituals
it makes sense in terms of the of the
actual geometric shape itself and you
can
explain it you can describe it so maybe
that's something i'll do
tetramorph says you definitely need a
better logo yeah my logo is a little
complicated what do you think
[Laughter]
yes i'm definitely aware that and so so
we'll work on it i still want to
i still want to keep that image of the
six days because i i really love that
image it's so perfect
in terms of of what it has so
i might keep it uh you know in different
ways but i need to need a better logo
that's for sure
so the per the company that's doing that
for me is name it's called modern animal
um and uh
the the the guy behind it nathan meffert
he he interviewed me at the very
beginning of all of this
like when just when jordan peterson uh
just came out with the jordan peterson
stuff he interviewed me for his podcast
which he had at the time
and um at the time he was like an
agnostic
just general kind of you know just basic
atheist type um and then since then he
has he's become fully engaged in the
catholic church and
is uh is married and uh just doing some
awesome stuff
and he he actually designed and is
selling a um
a a kind of devotional calendar
uh planner like uh you know like a kind
of like a
a regular planner that that is um that
you use with a like a book that's like a
planner but
in it is also all of the liturgical year
and there's this
this whole devotional aspect to his uh
his planner and so
so for catholics it's a pretty cool
thing it looks really nice too
um
all right so there's some discussion in
the uh in the chat about
about iconography and about idols and
all that stuff
and so i guess i have never really made
a video
about that directly i mean it probably
would be interesting to do that at some
point
and so for example boltz relic says
interesting enough he says nobody knows
how the incarnate christ looked however
and this is a really interesting uh it's
an interesting
argument it's interesting because it's a
it's a
it's a very technical argument it's like
one of those arguments
um that is missing the point
of why we have images of christ and so
let me let me use let me just exemplify
that for you quite
simply so you could say no one knows
what
christ actually looked like uh because
we don't
we don't because we haven't seen none of
us have seen him in the flesh
so we don't know what christ actually
looked like
i would actually dare argue that even if
you had a photograph of him you wouldn't
know what he looked like you would have
a semblance of him
um but none besides that
you could say the same about the name of
christ or the name of god you could say
nobody knows how that name is actually
pronounced
because we only have written versions of
it and you cannot
you cannot you cannot uh transmit
exactly
the sonority of something in a text
so because of that you don't know what
christ's name sounded like you don't
know what jesus actually sounded like
which means that you have a problem
right maybe you can't pray
you can't pray because you're calling
out this name that is probably doesn't
sound
like the name that uh that jews uh
used in the first century that is uh
like
it's not the same and so you know maybe
you you have no way of calling upon god
because you don't know what that name
sounded like
and so the technical argument is
actually quite useless it's
it's the the idea of this kind of weird
notion that you would know
because you don't know what christ
looked like uh
in a in a kind of very quantifiable
technical way
the fact of the image is real
the fact of the revelation of god's name
is real
and it doesn't depend on on a
it doesn't depend on the kind of
technicality of
of pronouncing it exactly the way that
people uh pronounced it
but rather this this
this communal coming together and this
recognition
together of how when we when i hear the
name jesus
i recognize that as talking about this
man when you hear me say it you
recognize it as well
and so together we are together in a in
a
in a communion where we recognize the
name of christ
obviously it can't be completely uh
completely removed from it and so
you know the name of christ couldn't be
just changed for the word doughnut
and neither could the image of christ be
changed for
you know uh red haired lady um
but there is a a kind of uh organic
reality of transmitting images and
names of receiving them of recognizing
them together
and that is how not just the image of
christ but that's actually how reality
works it's it's uh it doesn't it doesn't
rely as much on the kind of precise
technicality that you uh
that you're suggesting in that comment
so
all right
and so yeah not sam says even though we
don't know what christ looked like you
you never confuse him with someone else
when you see him an icon of him and of
course to avoid that problem
is one of the reasons why the um
the the fathers in the seventh
ecumenical council said that
for and let's say for an icon to be an
icon what it needs
is the image of the saint and then an
inscription of the name
which is why in orthodox icons they'll
always be
the name written if you want it to be an
image that will
participate in the life of the church
that will be venerated that will
it will be liturgical
so if an if an image doesn't have the
name of the saint it's not quite
an icon in the sense of a sacred image
and so
you can kind of it's like i'll tell you
guys a little secret it's like i'm
i play with that a little bit in the
sense that
for some of my let's say uh
semi-liturgical images or let's say
borderline liturgical images
sometimes i don't put an inscription
because i don't want people
to i want people to recognize what it is
that's going on but i also don't want
people to think that this is
exactly at the same level as an image
you would see in church
and that you would that would
participate in the liturgical life
so that's why if you notice that a lot
on a lot of t-shirts i'm doing
um i don't i don't write the name
of the st george or st michael um not to
say that i couldn't i mean maybe i could
it wouldn't be such a big deal but it's
a
it's one added kind of precaution so
that people don't
don't don't totally confuse this image
with uh
as being as the same level as the one
that would be in an icon stand in
church that it's it's in a hierarchy of
images
you guys know everything's is is in a
hierarchy
i would usually be carving faster than
this
i realize that it's actually demanding
more attention to me to carve
in wood and talk to you guys than it did
with
with the stone icon
so i'm going very slowly
[Music]
mm-hmm
um
all right so we're going into the beard
here
into the little details
so i'm curious to see if there's anybody
in the chat that has actually
started the the the wood the icon
carving
class online i'd be curious to see if
there are people that have and
what they think or what they how they're
how they're dealing with it
i realize that sometimes it might take a
little while before people get into it
because they need to buy the tools and
receive them so i understand if there's
some delay
all right and so
kind of happy with this hair not bad
yeah so spencer reel says he started
class but had no tools so i got stuck
same thing with jacob says he's ordered
the uh
the tool so yeah i figured that's what
we would that's what the situation would
be so i will be patient with you but
if you can like send me pictures you
guys
i really would like to see to see
uh to see some pictures of the how the
carvings are doing
that'd be cool there is one guy who sent
me some pictures on twitter
on uh on the direct messaging
and uh he was doing pretty well actually
he's doing pretty well
i think he had probably had tools
already
so the knife is really there to like
clarify certain things when especially
when it's little
like in here you can't maybe you can't
see it but there's like a nostril in
here so that's always really tricky very
small
all right so i'm going to make the lips
here this is going to be
a little tricky
so jacob says he has wood tools but not
exactly what we need yeah there's a few
tools that
are definitely are definitely i would
say important to have like this one this
number three
like a small one or a bigger one you can
it doesn't have to be the same size but
these number three tools they're magic i
love these
i mean these are the ones i use all the
time so if you have that and you have a
v tool
already it's not bad you've got a nice
you could probably start
so dog days of with storms as our 12
year old son and our
13 year old daughter will soon be
starting the course we already purchased
the course we too are waiting for the
tools and what to come in cool yeah
that's that's awesome
so make sure you make sure if you run
into some problems like i don't know if
there's a technical problem
or if uh you feel like some things are
not
clear make sure to to send me
to to contact me and to tell me because
if there's something that is like if
there's something that is really not
clear
the the course was tested out completely
with uh some guys in saskatoon they did
the whole week
and uh i was able to get their review
they seemed like they felt it was
it had everything you need but you never
know like if there's something you feel
is
really not clear there's still
i can still change it like i can still
let's say add another
another few minutes on on a video if um
if there's something that is totally
unclear my feeling is that it's it's
pretty good because like i said i i
already had it evaluated
and uh the the reaction was pretty
positive
so boltz really says so jonathan do you
mean to say that information
represented in the image is objective in
a symbolic transcendent sense
and as such it is not constrained by the
image
so i'm not sure i totally understand
your language but what i would say
is that there's a play there's a game or
there's an
exchange a dance between the identity of
something and
its potentiality in the world right and
so
that's also the same with an image and
so
you have to remember that the image is
not the per it's not the person
so it's like if you have a drawing or
photography or a photograph
of someone that's not the person this is
something also
this is actually one of the great
damages that photography has done to us
is that people think that the photo is
the same as a person that somehow the
photo
just represents a person without any any
you know any let's say language to it
and that's not true
for photography by the very framing
right even by the framing that is by the
fact that photography
limits the world to a a square
in which you decide what is important
that's already
a form of symbolic uh reality it's
already a compression of the world into
symbolic patterns so that's one then
second of all
uh there is a there's a game there's not
a game but there's an interplay
between let's say the potentiality of
of a being and then the way he's
represented and so
i could let's say i could represent you
a picture of you
in a few lines in a way that people
could recognize you like let's say like
in a caricature
um and people would recognize you in
those two lines
i could also take you know three weeks
to make a painting of you
that is trying to be as detailed as
possible
but even that painting will be will will
be an interpretation because
you're constantly moving you you don't
stay still like an
image a person isn't still like like in
a painting
and so even the stillness of the
painting is already a form
of of uh of let's say transformation
and so the idea is that there's a
there's a
there's a aspect to which an image
is
manifesting a being in a way that fits
the description or the
the memory of that being and then
there's a way that it's received
and then that kind of plays in there's a
play in between
these different these different things
so
um you could say that even for let's say
pictures a good example would be that
certain famous people have certain
pictures of them
which have become iconic of them and so
when you see
those pictures those are the pictures
which most
mostly typify a person um
and then there are other pictures that
don't so you could
experience that even in your own self
like haven't you ever taken a picture of
someone
uh on on let's say you take a picture of
of uh of your wife of your kid and then
when the
when you look at the picture in your
phone or in the camera
you think well that picture doesn't look
like them
and then you delete it and then you end
up keeping the pictures that
look like them but they look like them
because
there's already a there's already a kind
of language
relationship there's already a
relationship of seeing and receiving
and memory and how you remember how what
a what
constitute a being and so that's what
it's like for images but it's also the
same
for for anything any memory any story
you tell
you know it's the same with like let's
say even the gospels that are
that are told of christ that
these are in a symbolic filter in the
sense that they're
a compression of things which most
manifest
christ to the world because obviously
christ did a whole bunch of other stuff
it's not mentioned in the stories like i
don't know
tie his sandals or whatever like get
dressed in the morning
and you know all the things that people
do that aren't mentioned in scripture
uh not even speaking of the things which
which
might even have meaning that aren't
mentioned in scripture but those that
are more peripheral
and so that's actually how it all works
if there's this
this kind of dance between
memory recognition story compression
so whatever you whatever bothers you
about images
the question you need to ask yourself is
is
is it different for a story um
and stories also have the same issues
and problems that images have
in terms of the idea of a technical
technical representation of something
[Music]
so the sit ass why doesn't you not like
doing youtube stuff
i mean he is definitely an introvert and
uh
he he
you know he he doesn't like that kind of
attention he's just not
looking for it he i think he also
feels i mean i'm speaking for him which
is probably not a good idea but
i i think he also feels that in a way
when you make videos and you're kind of
speaking and you're
there's an aspect of yourself that
you're kind of compromising yourself to
a certain extent that you're
um yeah
i guess that's the best way to say it
but um
who knows you know i would love to have
him back on the channel but
at least for now he's he's clearly
communicated that he doesn't
because he doesn't want to do that
it's kind of moving all over the place
in this image here
i said i'm going to do the lips and then
i keep moving around
it's all you guys are distracting me you
know
so jacob asked if i made my workbench no
i didn't i mentioned that just a little
earlier it was made by my
cousin along a while ago like maybe
seven eight years ago he he made it as a
gift for me it's very nice
and yeah it's really a wonderful thing
because i i'm not the kind of person
that would have been very good at making
that for myself
don't worry for those who want to take
the the uh the icon carving class
all the things that i'm doing that i'm
not explaining right now i definitely
explained in the carbon class
i want you to think that i just kind of
carve and i make you guys watch me
tico says it looks very useful yeah it's
pretty cool it's a it's like
like i said it's a lazy susan uh with
like a clamp on it
so the clamp stops the lazy susan when i
need to stabilize it
and uh but there are some people that
i've seen that have made some uh
some simpler versions of this that are
actually pretty good
in terms of uh using
so for example my my assistant who works
in stone
he has like a piece of plywood on an
angle like this and then he
cut a um he cut like a
more like a little like a half circle in
it like that
and then he has a piece of uh plywood
that's cut in a circle
over it so it's like just two pieces of
two pieces of plywood on top of each
other
and so the the circle is kind of in the
half circle
so you can turn it but if you hit it
with a mallet
it tends to stay it's it hits the side
so it doesn't tend to move so much
and so just that for him is enough like
he just turns it and carves
and so it does the job for sure it's
helpful to turn like now i'm not turning
it because it keeps hitting the camera
up there
i should probably move it around but
usually i turn it way more
this is one of the reasons why i'm going
so slow now
it's mostly because i'm talking to you
guys though
so symbolic memes is there cool nice and
he says calling it lazy susan
is pretty susanist yes i have very
strong prejudices against
against susan's
i don't know am i wrong or i'm pretty
sure all the susans are lazy right
i mean if you met one susan you've met
them all right
hopefully there's nobody named susan in
the chat that would not be good
that would not be good i don't know
where that comes from the lazy susan
i don't know like what that what that uh
who came up with that name
i'm sure there's a spicy story behind
that like someone
who was angry at their spouse or
something and made it up and then
named it after them or something like
that
sure google has the answer to the origin
of lady susan
[Music]
so for those who ask what kind of wood
it is it is basswood or
linden which is kind of the more
technical name for
this particular type of basswood
and it's not it's northern basswood
really um because
one time i gave this workshop in um
south carolina
and uh i didn't i tend to i always
every time i did these workshops i would
like carry the wood across the border
so i would like put all these boards in
my luggage and you know fly with them or
or carry them down to the u.s and so i
thought it was really complicated and i
figured maybe i could buy local wood
while i'm down there or have someone buy
it and bring it to the workshop
so we found a place that had basswood
and we ordered it in south carolina but
it was very different it was
very very different it was way chippier
it wasn't as
uh as smooth as a northern bass would
and there's something about like there's
something that that's interesting to be
explored i haven't really taken the time
to do it but
for example northern basswood like this
stuff here
they'll they'll like cut it in the
middle of winter
on a full moon and all of this like
really weird stuff
uh and supposedly it's really to help
in terms of uh of its quality that if
you cut it in the winter then the sap is
not
is not uh in the um in the tree
and same thing like with the full moon
or something that how it affects the
the the quality of the wood i don't know
i don't i don't know if that's there's
any any
causality or any that's a physical uh
causality to that or if it's it's more
about attention and care
you know a lot of these things
one of the things i like to do is that
this is kind of um
just use a brush to remove some of the
slivers sometimes it's
just getting away
so nate asks what is the correct manner
of relating to science natural
philosophy as a physicist
workaholic i feel like in my profession
we struggle with idolatry
um i think it's just it's really it's
just about
understanding the limits of knowledge
and the limits of
the limit of certain types of knowledge
um and so
i think that a physicist has a lot of
has a lot of capacity to probably more
than
more just more
practically oriented type of of
scientists that would that would not be
able to see the limit of their knowledge
or the limit of the effect or the the
scope of their knowledge
seems like at least in physics
if that's what i understood you do then
there's at least the possibility
of recognizing the the limit of the
physical categories
of the quantifiable
so shadow beast must die says when i
made maple syrup the sap only runs
during the day
so yeah so maybe it is something to do
with sap running uh
during the day and then cutting it at
night so that the sap doesn't run
so that might be
that might be it
it doesn't explain why they have to like
turn seven times around the tree before
they cut it though
i'm actually joking that i've never
heard that i just like the idea
i just like the idea of like people uh
cutting down uh carving carving wood
to seeing it as some kind of like more
as a ritual or of some of some kind
more than just cutting wood it's just i
remember the first time someone told me
that they
cut in the dead of winter on a full moon
i thought wow man it's like am i
watching a
i feel like i'm watching some movie or
something
so paul r says do you feel like your
left hand is contributes to your
discernment of subtle patterns in
reality
i think that let's say this way i think
that
not left-handedness i think that
left-handedness
because as a left-handed person you you
actually have to
uh adjust yourself to the world more
um and so you have to the world is made
for right-handed people
so you have to adjust yourself to the
world and i think that that makes you
become aware of certain patterns so i
don't think it's only that but i do
think it
probably did play a little part in my
my own experience of patterns
one thing i'm i'm surprised that hasn't
happened yet is
is how no one has talked about the
marginal identity of left-handers
i mean if any category of person has
been mistreated and uh
and maligned in narrative until today
it's it's left-handed people
and it's like one in nine people in the
entire world or something
and so you know i think we need a
movement i think we think we need
like a left-handed uh woke movement to
to free the world from the constraint of
left-handed uh
hegemony you know so that we can uh
i mean think about it every time you
like walk into a room every time
that everything is made for live for
right-handed people there's like a
right-handed supremacy that we need to
uh
that we need to free ourselves for free
free ourselves from
anyways i'm feeling pretty cheeky here
as you can tell
talking about that
probably the reason why i don't want to
do too many of these live streams is
that i know that if i do these live
streams for too long
i'm really going to say something stupid
that i'll regret
but i don't regret the right-handed
comments
everybody knows right-handed people are
[Laughter]
bigots
oh man
all right so mcf asked if i will do more
in video games
everybody so many people ask me that and
that the the one i did on on on uh on
donkey kong got so few views that it
kind of bummed me out about it
um but i think a lot of people are still
asking me to do it i probably should
i probably should have chosen another
game besides donkey kong but
you know it's good it's always good to
interpret the origin of something
in order to understand what's going on
and so i i really did feel like donkey
kong
because it's because it's the first
narrative video game really
then it has a lot to offer
night arnold says video games are for
losers
i would say entertainment most most our
entertainment culture is
is not is not wonderful so but they're i
don't think i don't think video games
are worse than
watching netflix series or watching
movies
sorry you can hear my neighbor there
i think i think if you want to
understand like the whole the whole
uh video game thing i think a good way
to understand it that he really is like
a garment of skin
in the sense that you know i see people
in the chat saying that
that video games help them think
mythologically
and i think that's actually true um i
think that
on the one hand it can really be a place
for
people to get an intuition of these
patterns
you know uh like i haven't played those
games but i know like a lot of people
told me zelda has that and uh
i know that uh let's say the elder
scrolls has that kind of mythological
pattern in it
and so the problem is that so on the one
hand i think it's totally true and i
think it really can
jolt someone into into have mythological
understanding but it's also for that
same reason
it can also be dangerous to trap someone
at that level
it's almost like um a good exam a good
way to understand it would be something
like let's say spiritual experiences
if you read the church fathers the
church fathers
actually tend to speak against spiritual
experiences
they say you know be careful of
spiritual experiences
you know be doubtful of them question
them don't look for them don't search
them out because
on the one hand the spiritual experience
is the thing that will
make you often desire god
it can also have its own appeal which
will trap you at a certain level
and so you'll you'll you won't be able
to see further than
that experience so i think that that's
the danger that i see with video games
is that
is that some people get caught up in the
video game
world and then they they they don't live
their lives and so they they kind of
yes the video game offers them more
almost more mythological structure than
regular life and so because of that it
becomes a place where you want to be in
but then it can also be be a proxy uh
like a
like a crutch that you just carry along
and then you
and then you wonder why you you know you
can't learn to to walk and so
so i think that that's the situation so
i don't i think i i don't have a problem
with video games
i felt i see i noticed that during covid
i've played more
video games than i used to um
but at the same time we need to be
careful that
it's one of those things that can kind
of swallow you up because it's so
attractive and so and like it's
it's made to kind of to suck you in
so vt says how important is it to have
community when it comes to religious
practices
still finding my place in all this and i
live in a region with absolutely zero
orthodox community um yeah i i get i
feel you it's tough i think that it's
definitely
important uh but it's a it's hard like
even myself it's hard because
you know the world is the world is
messed
up right now and so you know my parish
for example like we're very few people
and we all live very far from each other
and so we don't
we don't have the chance of that they
seeing each other during the week or
communicating outside of church and so
it creates a
it doesn't it's not the ideal situation
and i think we're all dealing with that
we're all dealing with not ideal
situations
um and so you just have to do with what
you can
um
what he's talking about is exactly
what's happening in mm or rpgs men are
growing up wondering
why they aren't as fun as they used to
be when they should be applying those
patterns to life
yeah that i think that that's what
that's what i see is the problem with
with uh video games like i said is that
it's
that it's it's so encompassing and there
and also
let's say the stakes are so low you can
get a major
kick and a major let's say kind of uh
a very condensed pattern with very
little consequence
and so it's easy to get drawn in and to
then just
live to live there because
because yeah you know it's it's it's
like
eating uh it's like eating fast food you
know it's like eating uh
eating candy
my neighbors out there talking about
talking something with
to my wife and i i just told them so you
know you're on youtube right now right
they're like okay we need to go
somewhere else and talk about this
so matthew says as a fellow left-handed
person i'm looking forward to purchasing
your course very soon
cool yeah i'm really looking forward to
seeing how people react to that
um
it also helped me kind of decide if i'm
gonna do a second one
probably will especially because kobe
doesn't seem like kobe's going away soon
so at least here
the people are completely
taken up
so feels like we're going to be in
lockdown for
still quite a long time
all right folks i think i'm gonna stop
it's actually harder to carve wood on
here than it is
to um to uh to carve stone just because
i feel more distracted and it's trickier
because you know stone i can't i can't
just
move the tool and i make a major mistake
it's like here
but i'm not careful i can just fleck a
piece off the
wood off and that's it
all right so since people had asked for
me to do these uh
these kind of uh live in progress work
things
i might um i might do a last one so i
did it one in stone i didn't doing one
would i might do a last one
where i'll be drawing and so you can you
can if you're interested in watching me
drawing i might do that
in the next few weeks
removed a little bit not as much as i
would have if i had been
just working so all right guys thanks
for
for uh for tuning in
it was fun just to do a little bit of
this so you can see
me wood carving and uh and yeah so i
should be
hopefully be putting out some uh
some videos pretty soon you know and uh
for some reason they're all gonna be
about
satanic imagery hopefully that won't
last very long
and uh and so yeah so thanks to
everybody for
dropping in thanks to jacobs about memes
i saw lisa was there
and uh brad and uh two more v's
is there sweet it's good to see you who
else is there
that i know
all right guys i will
see you soon
you